[Musique]
bonjour françois durpaire
merci de nous accorder cet entretien
vous êtes historien spécialiste des
états unis on va parler de l'amérique on
va parler de donald trump un petit virus
aura-t-il raison du président américain
alors avec le co vide on a découvert un
colosse aux pieds d'argile comment vous
expliquez l'impréparation américaine
l'impréparation du président américain
ya l'impréparation du système américain
notamment de son système de santé qui
est très performant il suffit simplement
de voir le nombre de prix nobel de
médecine c'est considérable mais c'est
un système qui est fait pour la médecine
j'allais dire pour les plus riches mais
qui ne permet pas de soigner le plus
grand nombre et puis il ya le président
américain ce président américain qui
devait près ce virus il allait d'est en
ouest les états unis pouvaient s'y
préparer eh bien il a fait le choix de
ne pas regarder de ne pas écouter ces
experts ne pas regarder ce qui se
passait dans les rapports et depuis
longtemps des services américains qui
disait mais la pandémie c'est une des
menaces qui touchent notre pays alors
les conséquences économiques elles sont
brutales 40 millions d'emplois détruits
des faillites en cascade et des
américains qui se retrouvent sans
couverture maladie est ce qu'on peut
dire que le virus il a entièrement
ruinés le bilan économique de donald
trump alors il faut le dire rapidement
parce que le rebond peut aussi être fort
aux états unis on le sait c'est une
société qui est très souple sur le plan
économique et on a déjà des prémices de
reprise 1 2 million cinq cent mille
emplois recréer des ventes au détail qui
reprennent de manière très importante
simplement on sait qu'une partie
l'élection est peut-être tout l'élection
se jouera sur cette question économique
donald trump prépare dans les semaines à
venir un grand plan une sorte de new
deal pour relancer cette économie et
évidemment les américains ils vont voter
surtout pas pour l'économie générale pas
pour l'économie des économistes mais
selon leur portefeuille et ils se diront
au moment de voter et est ce que
finalement ce président nous permet et
bien de reconstruire ce qui a été
détruit pendant la crise ducobu 19 en
attendant l'amérique se déchire on a
rarement connu deux divisions aussi
profonde car dans le sillage du coc vide
s'est rajouté la sphère de l'assassinât
de georges floyd et la question raciale
qui s'est invité dans la société
américaine les pro et les anti trust se
dit vide est-ce que depuis la guerre de
sécession on a connu pareil face à face
alors c'est vrai vous avez cité la
guerre de sécession qu'on appelle aux
états unis la guerre civile donc on
n'est pas plus divisé aux états unis que
pendant la guerre civile c'est une
évidence mais on n'est peut-être pas
plus divisée que pendant les années 60
où à l'époque où déjà les étudiants
étaient dans la rue et déjà une majorité
silencieuse faisait la victoire de
richard nixon là on estime par exemple à
6% le nombre d'américains qui sont
descendus dans la rue un million
d'américains beaucoup d'américains sont
restés chez eux la différence c'est que
la division aujourd'hui elle est
peut-être politique c'est à dire que les
camps sont bien délimités et jusqu'à
maintenant les institutions permettait
de faire les états unis d'amérique les
états unis elle était divisée mais les
institutions étaient unificatrice est à
dire que vous pouviez être un député de
gauche aient voté à droite où l' inverse
ça c'était une tradition américaine
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas vous
savez si vous êtes républicain bien pour
qui vous allez voter il ya une
discipline des partis qui n'existait pas
avant dans ce pays puis la division
raciale vous avez raison en parler c'est
pas exactement l'amérique en noir et
blanc de la fin des années 60 au moment
où le rapport carnet un disait cette
société en train de se diviser entre
noirs et blancs pour trois raisons
d'abord la poussée des hispaniques
aujourd'hui il ya un américain sur cinq
qui est hispanique la poussée globale
des minorités en 2050 la majorité des
américains seront minoritaires enfin
c'est à dire que les blancs seront
minoritaires aux états unis et puis la
troisième chose c'est la mixité le
métissage on oublie souvent mais faut
pas oublier qu'un cinquième des couples
américains marié le son entre des
communautés différentes puis à la
révolution blanche aux états unis c'est
à dire qu'il ya beaucoup de blancs qui
aujourd'hui ont conscience du racisme de
leur société aujourd'hui il ya vraiment
une amérique blanche qui se dit ce n'est
pas acceptable ce ratio est ce qu'on
peut superposer les divisions qui sont
nés avec le co vide entre les pro et les
anti trump les antilles masques et les
pros masque à cette division raciale
après ce qui s'est passé avec jake lloyd
entre ceux qui ont manifesté mis parfois
un genou à terre et ceux qui refusent de
regarder ce problème oui c'est cette
guerre culturelle on l'a vu elle s'est
traduite sur le plan politique et vous
avez raison de faire référence aux
masques comment ce masque qui en france
et dans l'ensemble du monde n'est qu'un
outil de protection contre un virus peut
devenir à ce point aux états unis un
outil politique à tel point que porter
le masque aux états unis ça veut dire
être opposé au président américain ne
pas le porter c'est l'assurance que vous
allez voter pour le président américain
c'est un signal politique très très fort
ça veut dire que quand vous parlez un
américain vous pouvez lui poser la
question de l'avortement vous pouvez lui
poser la question des armes à feu vous
pouvez lui poser la question des
relations entre communautés et vous
savez à peu près ce que cet américain va
voter dans quelques mois concernant les
relations internationales l'ordre
international là aussi on voit que la
crise accélère des tendances un peu près
existantes les etats unis ne veulent
plus être le gendarme du monde trump le
dis et redis america's first est ce que
cette tendance c'est une tendance de
fond qui va continuer à exister après
train la tendance de fond c'est le
retrait progressif de la scène
internationale des états unis ont lavé
version obama avec le
multilatéralisme et on l'a avec donald
rave et ça s'appelle l'unilatéralisme et
l'isolationnisme donc c'est pas
exactement la même manière de se retirer
mais c'est une manière de se retirer des
affaires du la grande idée c'est vous
savez ce qu'on appelle le piège de
thucydide ces deux nations ses parts
d'un côté athènes de l'autre qui se
diviser et la guerre devait forcément
avoir lieu cette guerre du péloponnèse
parce que athènes était en train de
monter et sparte voyez sa position
dominante un peut renier c'est ce qui se
passe avec la chine du côté chinois
c'est à tête et du côté etats unis c'est
sparte beaucoup beaucoup de chercheurs
disent que c'est ça qui va se passer
mais c'est pas du tout évident parce que
vous le voyez à l'occasion du coup vide
les chinois ne cherche pas
nécessairement à aller chercher des
sphères d'influencé certes il ya la mer
de chine niçois heaven est influent dans
leur espace mais un cas très concrets
l'afrique l'afrique évidemment avec la
route de la soie les chinois vont
chercher des zones d'influencé mais que
les américains ont déjà abandonné de
n'être jamais allé en afrique au cours
de son premier mandat la chine prend une
place finalement que les états unis ont
déjà laissé et la chine n'a pas
nécessairement intérêt vu l'interaction
des économies l'un est vendeur l'autre
est prêt acheteurs on n'a pas
nécessairement envie de se faire la
guerre c'est pour ça que quand on parle
de guerre froide entre n'y croyez les
états unis c'est un mot qui ne convient
pas parce que la guerre froide c'était
entre des pays qui n'avaient pas autant
d'interaction en tout cas sur le plan
économique l'amérique d'après est ce
qu'elle peut être incarnée par joe biden
alors la question c'est est ce que joe
biden aujourd'hui peut perdre cette
élection vous allez me dire on a dit la
même chose d'hillary clinton qui
semblait très très bien partie
aujourd'hui des à +10 c'est quand même
une avance assez considérable et il est
entre 6 et 9 dans quatre états clés sans
être trop technique alors pourquoi joe
biden a une position plus solide par
rapport à hillary clinton d'abord parce
qu'il a compris quelque chose il faut
qu'il ait le vote des étudiants le vote
des jeunes qui ont voté pour bernie
sanders dans l'élection primaire alors
il a déjà verdi son programme qui est
beaucoup plus écolo qu'avant il a aussi
parlé d'une université gratuite donc il
a intégré quand même beaucoup de choses
du programme de bernie sanders il ya le
discours de donald trump qui a une
rhétorique extrêmement violente la loi
et l'ordre et là on peut dire que
beaucoup d'étudiants vont voter pour joe
biden pour ne pas voter pour donald
trump et puis enfin un point c'est qu'il
aa clinton était très clivante ce que
n'est pas joe biden chez les
indépendants c'est très clair joe biden
est plus aimé qu hillary clinton d'été
et il est surtout moins détesté il ya un
écart de 20 points c'est considérable
entre la détestation que hillary clinton
pouvait subir et joba de hockey de
maiden rassemble davantage il va
chercher les femmes les noirs les
minorités qui certes se disent
démocrates mais n'avait pas forcément
mis un bulletin dans l'urne l'action
précédente c'est à dire il va chercher
les indépendants et il a de fortes
possibilités d'avoir plus de gens qui se
mobilisent pour lui ça c'est fondamental
c'est à dire que la rhétorique de denain
on le dit souvent dans les
reportages elle mobilise son camp mais
elle a aussi pour effet de mobiliser le
camp adverse et ce qui s'est passé lors
des élections mi terme en 2018 tous les
démocrates l'ont emporté que vous parlez
la question du monde après pour les
états unis ce monde apprend le voit déjà
se redessiner on voit notamment dans les
entreprises de la silicon valley des
gens qui restent en télétravail et qui
ne retrouvent pas leur entreprise on
voit des étudiants qui ne repart pas sur
leur campus et c'est l'éducation à
distance et on voit peut-être une
élection se profiler avec un vote par
correspondance
de plus en plus massif et donc une
démocratie numérique qui semble émerger
donc ce monde après en quelque sorte de
copie de 19 à accélérer des évolutions
vous rappelez de ceux de ce livre de
seth de cet écrivain canadienne naomi
klein qui disait eh bien il ya un
capitalisme du désastre à chaque fois
qu'il ya un événement désastreux via des
évolutions qui se font jour elle avait
étudié quatre et nara qui était un
désastre américain et là c'est à
l'échelle du pays quel avenir vous voyez
à ce parti démocrate est ce que il c'est
joe biden idées avec une forme de centre
de gravité plutôt modéré où on voit et
vous le disiez il a intégré des éléments
notamment pour la jeunesse une
partie radicaliser plus radicalisés à
gauche avec des figures comme alexandria
occasion cortès qui vient de remporter
la primaire notamment pour le congrès à
new york il y à il ya deux camps au sein
des démocrates oui très clairement il ya
un camp beaucoup plus radicale beaucoup
plus féminisé et surtout beaucoup plus
écologiste ce camp écologiste favorable
à new deal il fait référence à roosevelt
cette grande figure démocrate mais un
new deal vert vient ce camp-là veut
évidemment modifier l'adn de joe biden
pourtant joe biden était l'un des
premiers il a un héritage écolo il a été
l'un des premiers à faire signer le loi
sur l'écologie et sur l'émission de co2
donc il faut qu'il aille chercher un peu
dans sa jeunesse de parlementaires mais
évidemment il ya ces deux camps au sein
du parti démocrate et vous avez vous
n'allez pas être surpris si je vous dis
que le camp de l'avenir il est du côté
des plus jeunes et c'est ces jeunes ils
sont dans l'idée donc on appelle c'est
un peu complexe l'internationalité c'est
à dire ils sont à la fois anti sexistes
pro écolo antiraciste donc ce sont
presque des activistes ce sont des
activistes qui sont parlementaire et qui
dit il faut changer la politique
américaine et surtout faut réconcilier
les citoyens américains avec leur
politique est le parti républicain que
restera-t-il du parti républicain si
trump n'est n'est pas réélu est ce qu'il
existe encore un camp modéré républicain
ou est ce que les républicains ont été
très prisés les républicains et être en
pisé bien avant donald trump s'est
d'ailleurs qu'avant donald trump il ya
eu le tea party et si on veut vraiment
être précis sur le plan politique c'est
pas donald trump qui a trente pisé ce
parti c'est la radicalité elle vient du
tea party elle est antérieure à donner
un train bloque la question c'est est-ce
que cette voie de la radicalité va
continuer ou est-ce que ces américains
vont se dire du fait de l'évolution je
vous parlais au début de l'émission de
ces américains blancs non hispaniques
qui seront minoritaires en 2050 de cette
amérique métisse qui est en train
d'évoluer et de cette amérique qui a
envie d'écologie est ce que ce parti
républicain va pas se dire viens on va
faire on va intégrer d'autres choses
dans ce parti et on va pas oublier que
nous sommes le parti d'abraham lincoln
le parti de l'abolition de l'esclavagé
est-ce qu'elle réconciliables dans
l'amérique d'après cette amérique c'est
amérique cette america se pousse sans
cesse la question son unité c'est le nom
du pays étaient unis d'amérique estados
unidos du côté des éditorialistes
d'extrême droite on en a en france on en
a aux états unis qu'ils disent mais que
le dernier anglo saxon a quitté miami en
porte le drapeau américain nous sommes
submergés par ces vagues hispanique
c'est une partie de la victoire de
donald trump ce qui restera peut-être
c'est son agenda identitaire et c'est ça
que beaucoup d'américains entendent
quand ils votent pour donald trump si
donald trump et là ils nous protègent
ils nous protègent de l'évolution de
cette amérique de ces invasions
d'hispaniques c'est ce qu'ils ont dans
la tête n'ont en tout cas et ils nous
permettent peut-être de continuer à
parler anglais alors évidemment ils ont
tort pourquoi mais parce que tous les
chercheurs en sciences sociales montrent
que ces hispanique qui arrive il parle
anglais c'est à dire que ça marche dans
les deux sens il donne des prénoms anglo
saxons à leurs enfants et donc il ya une
anglaise de sinisation aussi des vagues
d'immigrants ça a toujours été en fait
le processus de l'intégration américaine
merci beaucoup merci françois du regard
[Musique]